well i can i can say i'm a guilty
offender being a former or some extent
being a media reporter i think it's you
know journalists are in a lot of ways a
self-absorbed Bunch and and they love to
talk about themselves and in some extent
write about themselves so but i think
that so you know it's an interesting
debate that's about you know how the how
the how the campaign was covered versus
what what happened on the ground and i
think it it's been one of the running
story lines of this campaign of how how
little anyone really knows about what's
going on and and and i think the larger
context stepping back is it's the
country is at this sort of inflection
point of and and Obama has made this a
cornerstone of his campaign of the the
narratives of the past you know several
elections are you know we're at this
point where we could go laughter we
could go right and and no one really
knows where where it's going to go and
and and obama is representing you know
what he says is a break from the past
and in Hillary is is is representing
what she says is the the best attributes
of the Clinton years and McCain is is
harking back even earlier to Ronald
Reagan and it's the electorate is trying
to digest all that and decide are we are
we going to embrace these these previous
candidates are we willing to quote turn
the proverbial page and and start a new
chapter 22 whatever the political
narrative will be
you